wir schauen gemeinsam auf einen mann der
am boden war karriere kaputt leben
kaputt johnny depp aber dann der sieg
vor gericht gegen seine ex amber heard
und jetzt ist er größer denn je johnny
depp er ist weg und das in deutschland
schauen sie hier hier kommt da gerade an
bad in der menge fotos mit fans
autogramme das ganze ja tatsächlich in
offenbach unsere bild reporterin an die
garage die hat einen tag heute mit
johnny depp verbracht vor seinem mega
konzert dort na ja fast zumindest
johnny depp ist beck und hier läuft er
durch die frankfurter innenstadt weil er
in der gegend ein konzert hat doch wir
müssen ihnen gestehen das ist nicht der
echte johnny depp aber egal ob du bin
oder echter johnny die fans feiern ihn
denn seit der gewonnenen
gerichtsschlacht gegen ex frau amber
heard ist er zurück egal ob am filmset
oder auf der konzertbühne die einzigen
die immer hinter ihm stehen natürlich
seine fans
wir haben uns gefragt dies ist einer der
bekanntesten schauspieler der welt zu
sein wie reagieren die menschen auf der
straße deshalb haben wir jack elliott
johnny depp du bill getroffen bild
reporterin an die courage haben
nachgefragt was neben den abgeranzten
schuhen noch wichtig ist für das doodle
aussehen was macht so den johnny depp
block aus ja natürlich hat der johnny
depp viele ketten viele so schals oder
auch solche dinger hier dann hat er
entweder schiebermützen oder auch
richtige hüte dann eine der bekannten
brüllen ist so eine trifft auch andere
wollen ja die tattoo sollte hier wobei
da werde ich nicht alle drauf machen
sind das denn die die original tattoo
sozusagen die auch johnny depp dann auf
den abend trägt oder ja genau das sind
so ein original
und eine wichtige frage die man sich bei
jedem google stellt tragen sie die
sachen dann auch wirklich privat oder
nur wenn sie in die rolle schlüpfe also
wäre johnny depp stil auch ihr stil wäre
auch mein spiel nur ich würde jetzt
tagsüber nicht so rumlaufen oder die
wird sehen die brüllende habe ich auch
so eine ähnliche brille nicht original
und ja so normal
also schon ein johnny depp jubel der las
liebt was er tut und deshalb geht es in
die zauberkugel und aus jack wie johnny
depp mit seinen tattoos doch vor allem
als du will von skandalnudel johnny hat
man auch sorgen
jetzt hatte johnny depp ja in den
letzten zwei jahren absolutes
karrieretief dadurch dass er eben in den
anhörungen gegen seine ex frau steckte
wie groß war da ihre sorge dass ihr
eigenes geschäftsmodell zusammenbrechen
könnte ja wie gesagt gute frage
natürlich wenn der prozess zum nachteil
verlaufen wäre hätte das auch einfluss
auf meine jubel karriere nehmen können
weiß man natürlich nicht aber
grundsätzlich glaube ich schon
unabhängig davon sind die leute auf die
webseite gewesen weil ich hatte auch
jetzt noch ein paar auftritte und da
lief der prozess noch und die leute
waren ja weiterhin unheimlich freundlich
nett und hat keiner irgendetwas
schlechtes gesagt also die fans lieben
ihren johnny und damit auch sein jubel
dickes auto bodyguards und ein geiles
outfit das gehört zu einem guten
auftritt von johnny depp einfach dazu
aber auf eine sache muss dass du will
immer achten auf events davon sich nicht
betrinken in die kunden da sind man darf
so tun als ob und die ganzen anderen
seriosität und das was wir heute machen
damit man englisch gesprochen da muss
ich die tonlage ein bisschen tiefer
machen und so bist du tun als wir nicht
so erwehren
wenn man so unauffällig unterwegs ist
dann erkennt der eine oder andere fan
johnny depp natürlich ich will mir gar
nicht sicher ob es wirklich nicht ob es
tatsächlich
könnte schon sein aber ansonsten sehr
menschlich sehr natürlich sehr schön
aber ich wusste gar nicht dass er hier
ist in deutschland für ein konzert
glaube ich hab ich gehört gehen wie für
mich ist hier gehen wir nicht so ganz
glauben dass sie gepflegt
es war so als ob er genau die rolle wie
auch bei flut karibik auch jetzt ewig
gespielt hat egal ob du bist oder der
echte johnny depp egal ob auf der
leinwand oder auf der bühne wir können
festhalten johnny depp ist
[Musik]
annika an der stimme muss auch noch ein
bisschen arbeiten aber rein äußerlich
muss ich sagen chapeau konnte dem echten
johnny depp schon ziemlich nahe ein tag
mit ihm heute unterwegs gewesen was war
das verrückteste was euch heute passiert
ist
ja ich muss ehrlich gesagt gestehen dass
ich damit gerechnet hätte dass die leute
eher schmunzeln und er daran vorbeigehen
als ich davon gehört habe dass eben
diese stufe zu sagt dieser jack elliott
als ich ihn getroffen habe habe ich
gemerkt wie ernst diesen job genommen
hat er hat sich dann umgezogen für zehn
minuten das ging ja nicht ganz schnell
und kann dann raus aus dem badezimmer
und da mussten wir wirklich mein
kameramann und ich ein bisschen
schlucken weil er wirklich
johnny depp wirklich ähnlich sagt und
dann sind wir in die stadt gegangen und
das verrückteste war eigentlich dass ich
am anfang noch gedacht hätte dass viele
menschen auch einfach dran vorbei gehen
würden aber er sei wirklich so täuschend
echt aus dass tatsächlich eine riesen
traube um uns und um ihn gebildet hat
und die menschen wirklich mann hat in
die gesichter guckt man wusste die wir
menschen überlegen ist er das wirklich
das kann ja eigentlich gar nicht sein
einer frankfurter innenstadt und dieser
mann nimmt diesen job sehr sehr ernst
und das hat sich am ende bezahlt gemacht
was sagt die reporterin alica rasch die
johnny depp ja längst begegnet ist unter
anderem beim prozess in london bei dem
ersten langen prozess heute aber nach
dieser ganzen gerichtsprozess orgie dort
was wir live im fernsehen die ganze zeit
verfolgt haben hier gebannt ist er jetzt
halt auf der straße hier in deutschland
und wie reagieren die menschen jetzt auf
ihn
auf das duell oder auf den echten johnny
depp ja sozusagen auf den echten wenn
sie es noch nicht gemerkt haben also
trägt man dem was nach oder ist er
wirklich weg ist er so groß wie nie
zuvor im grunde johnny
also man muss wirklich sagen johnny depp
ist beziehungsweise war nie weg so
wirkte das zumindest weil diese traube
wirklich riesengroß war die menschen es
machen wollten ihn umarmen wollten
anfassen wollten ein autogramm wollten
also da hat man wirklich gar nichts von
diesen zwei prozess jahren dies am ende
ja fast waren gemerkt und johnny depp
wirkte so groß wie ing
danke an die bild reporterin an die
garage die heute den ganzen tag mit
johnny depp naja fast verbracht hat dort
in offenbach danke dir für den moment
und jetzt wollen wir aber auch den
echten sehen natürlich unbedingt oder
nachlasses direkt nach offenbach gehen
denn das spiel heute abend und da ist
unsere kollegin jessica fälle fort
hallo ich habe mich heute den echten jin
gesehen gerade mal zehn minuten her oder
so noch so ein bisschen im freudentaumel
weil natürlich ist auch für mich etwas
besonderes und was da alles in hollywood
star zu sehen es auch viel kleiner als
ich eigentlich dachten dass ich mir
vorgestellt habe er kam halt raus
backstage von hinter mir sieht man
gesagt die schlange fürs konzert auf der
anderen seite ist da wechselt ausgang da
kann man nämlich nach seinem soundcheck
draus und hat noch mal all seinen fans
hallo gesagt hat sie umarmt autogramme
gegeben dass ich wirklich eine halbe
stunde zeit ungefähr genommen die leute
war natürlich komplett aus dem häuschen
du auch wie man merkt ja was macht er
denn nun ganz genau da heute abend er
spielt mit jeff beck mit seinem kumpel
zusammen ist ja auf der bühne wird für
singen und gitarrespielen
konzert ticket kostet um die 9 und 3 93
euro hier sind auch schon ein paar die
alten schild hoch und wollen suchen noch
vergeblich nach tickets war ich glaube
wir sind wirklich ausverkauft also
diesem heute komplett ausverkauft
restkarten nun fragt man sich natürlich
was macht denn johnny depp wenn er in
offenbach ist wo der dennoch gibts das
schöne hotels in denen absteigen kann
wissen wir wo er wohnt also was hast du
zu berichten also mein erster impuls war
ja auch seit ich gehört dass johnny depp
in offenbach spielt und ich in frankfurt
dass er wohl im motel one absteigen wird
hh aber er ist gar nicht in offenbach
ist in kronberg im schlosshotel und da
hat er sich jetzt die ganze zeit
aufgehalten gestern abend war ich auch
vor ort hat auch gelauert vor seinem
hotel wärme hat geschaut aber vielleicht
irgendwo es dabei rauskommt aber in
einem taxi von irgendwo zurückkommt er
soll sich die ganze zeit in seinem hotel
gefunden haben das ist so das was wir
aus internen kreisen rausgefunden haben
aber das hotel von ihrem ist schön kann
man es ansehen ich da warst du sicher
nicht die einzige die vor diesem hotel
gestanden hatte wie viele frauen wie
vielen frauen bist du begegnet
ich war die einzige und ich war mir auch
ein bisschen peinlich als einmal das
raus kamen und sich gefragt hat was ich
dann macht man sich an sagt johnny depp
ich kam mir vor wie ein groupie weil so
viele leute waren da gar nicht wir waren
da mit einem fotografen kollegen und
sonst waren 23 autogrammjäger noch dabei
weil ich glaube das war eigentlich noch
ziemlich toxic wird das wussten nicht so
viele leute dass johnny depp darunter
bekommt es erst heute morgen kamen dann
mehrere leute und ein paar medienserver
da was eigentlich ganz ruhig da hat das
hotel eigentlich dann auch gute
inkognito arbeit geleistet okay wir
beenden schnell das gespräch klassiker
der mitte sofort rein kannst keinen
moment versorgen musste bericht exter
heute abend gemacht bleibt eben ihr in
der nacht seinen bleibt ihm hat er
spuren jessica verleih unsere bild
reporterin und johnny depp groupie
neuerdings na ja es geht